lula da silva recibió la segunda dosis
de la vacuna china de sinovac el
expresidente brasileño aprovechó la
ocasión para lanzar un mensaje al actual
presidente aunque ha dicho que es el
candidato no es su prioridad se espera
que lula sea el principal rival de
bolsonaro en las presidenciales de 2022
solo tienen que hacer una cosa escuchar
a la ciencia a aquellos que saben y
cumplir con sus obligaciones
pero más allá de las tensiones políticas
la situación en brasil es preocupante
marzo fue el mes más mortal de la
pandemia con más de 66 mil fallecidos y
con un promedio en las últimas jornadas
de 3.000 muertos diarios
una situación que analizó el director de
la sociedad abierta de fundaciones de
américa latina y el caribe pedro
abramovay para france24 pero yo creo que
un jefe de estado debería ser más
prudente y trabajar en conjunto con los
cobradores que están intentando al día
con las crisis es muy muy grave los
hospitales la preocupante situación
epidemiológica se encuentra con una
realidad muy distinta en la calle son
habituales las patrullas policiales que
descubren fiestas clandestinas como esta
del viernes en sao paulo en la que más
de 100 personas se encontraban
celebrando sin medidas de seguridad la
pregunta hasta cuándo que más tiene que
pasarle a la sociedad oa este tipo de
personas que frecuentan estos
establecimientos clandestinos para darse
cuenta de que no es el momento para
hacer esto
en este clima de crisis política
sanitaria y cívica continúan
paralelamente las vacunaciones pese al
lento avance están llegando a remotas
aldeas indígenas del amazonas